étranger
[Musique]
Je ne me souviens de rien
Je me souviens seulement de
L'Interprète
[Musique]
pourquoi il veut son travail j'ai besoin de l'argent
ne déçois pas s'avère être un emmerdeur
non pas moi monsieur l'
argent n'est pas  la raison pour laquelle il veut son travail
et les talibans ont tué son fils
arrêtent le véhicule qui démarre nous ne voulons pas
emprunter cette route tu es hors de tes
limites Ahmed tu es là pour traduire
en fait je suis là pour interpréter
Howie approche
bien je  veux
redescendre pendant trois semaines cette famille
a cru que tu étais mort nous sommes l'homme
ta vie il ne lui suffisait pas de
me porter à travers ces montagnes
non il se cache dans un trou quelque part je
devrais être dans ce trou
tout va bien John non
tout va  pas d'accord il y a un
crochet en moi Ahmed et sa famille ont des
problèmes nous ne pouvons pas intervenir je
suis en fait sur moi-même
écoutez vous allez être seul
voici ce que vous avez
si vous pouvez me donner l'emplacement si je peux
les obtenir  hors du pays c'est trop
dangereux
tu deviens très populaire auprès des talibans tu me
manques t'aime papa
tu penses que si je pouvais être libéré de cette
dette je ne le serais pas
tu penses que j'ai le choix
il n'y a pas le choix non je ne le ferai pas
reculer